Hey
busy I don't want to take up to your
time but I'm gonna kill myself I just
thought that an adult should know oh I
wish I knew what to say you know
actually I was writing my own
I'm suicide not just now as some of you
know I have 32 fleeting minutes of
happiness during lunch which has been
eaten up again and again by the same
especially badly grass student and I
finally thought I would rather have the
dark nothing you have a nice life
without any [ __ ] there are two types
of people in the world the people who
radiate confidence and naturally excel
at life golden boys oh and the people
who hope all those people die in a big
explosion look at that stupid shirt my
brother's right screams I have a body
complex worse than a girls when I was 13
it was clear which side of the equation
I was on oh my god I knew it it's really
just the hair you can roll it out nope
but that's what best friends are for oh
my god Nick is like right there God juvy
made him so hot and I had Krista Krista
John just want the [ __ ] seriously my
brother
think about how shitty this is for me I
can't help how I feel
what if I like your dad what if I gave
your dad a [ __ ]
Oh Louis why you look so hot with that
belt phone no oh no oh well Krista
you're home early
I'm not even gonna respond to that you
turn into a completely different person
you actually love being part of that
exclusive little group I'm having a
problem today maybe several I don't
really have any friends at the moment
why don't you try being positive mom you
always say the same thing you know write
down the next thing you're gonna say to
me I'm not playing you little games
maybe congratulations you have all the
answers don't you know which is why I
wish I had a mother who would notice
when I was young so much younger than
today brother invited me to a party on
Friday and I want you to come with us
please help what did I do to make such a
perfect kid huh
these days are gone I'm not so self the
show tell me our word socialize
I need somebody your dairy and
Franklin's sister yeah what's that movie
that's got Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
short bald guy they play twin brothers
only Arnold's all tall and buff right
mother guys like little and
funny-looking yes oh God
our twins yes great movie you and your
brother kind of remind me that
life isn't fair sometimes Nadine okay
you got to get over it
my life isn't perfect either the one
person who makes me happy I can't have
without completely destroying
life's about taking risks don't be
afraid to put yourself out there Nick I
like you and I just want to be with you
I want you to put your mouth in my tits
we can do it in the petland stockroom
Nadine I can't send this huh no no no no
no no no no my god no listen so bad I
just want to be with you want you to put
your mouth on my tits I want to feel you
in silent God you can do it in the
headlands dock room oh my god say
something please help me you need to
watch out for run-on sentences
oh my god [ __ ] yeah looks like he works
out quite a bad step you get him up here
please Skippy's turns out her boyfriend
is this internet zillionaire I'm so
[ __ ] psyched to drive